we're seeing the amazing spider-man 2 I
thought the opening 10 minutes were
really incredible some of my favorite
spider-man things ever done electro was
a very good villain I thought hey i'm
ryan and now i'm david and weird our new
offices at fandango very happy to be
here and we are here to give our first
review in the new office of the amazing
spider-man 2 starring Andrew Garfield
who is quite a hipster awesome
spider-man yes and Emma Stone who is the
most divine Gwen Stacy I can possibly
imagine at one point just to start off
with those guys at one point in the
middle of the movie I said to my friend
they're going to set fires with all
these sparks the chemistry is off the
chart it's an electric yes electro well
it's a punny day everybody um ok so just
initial thoughts there will be spoilers
and when we give like major spoilers
will give you a heads up but like
initial thoughts I loved it I enjoyed it
I do not agree with all the mixed
reviews I think it's a good a good
spider-man movie very confusing choices
though it is a bit redundant to see
harry osborn turn into Green Goblin
again it is um again this this movie is
fighting against the fact that it's a
reboot of a franchise that existed
recently because I think that this is a
really really very strong comic book
movie from an objective standpoint but
it's also fighting against the fact that
there was a franchise already if the
last if the Sam Raimi's movies didn't
exist I feel like people would be like
this is great yeah it's not like
spider-man free reinvent of Gwen Stacy
and Mary Jane and then like 18 other
characters and they're all just messing
with each other I think the balance
shows really well in this I think
because you don't really have electro
and green goblin who team up quite well
yeah and the Rhinos only in this movie
for four minutes this movie is really
fun it's yeah right it's colorful it
reminded me completely of the Fox
animated Saturday morning cartoon show
yeah
it's very very like you can even tell
there's so many like kids that spider
mites talking to literally in the movie
that this is geared towards kids yeah
they really play into this idea of spot
like friendly neighborhood spider-man
the amount of citizens of New York that
he interacts with and like you said the
kids and you also really feel the
presence of New York in this movie they
shot the entire thing there and the last
one they shot a lot of it in Los Angeles
um this one you can really feel it I
thought jamie foxx's Electro's really
good they they went a kind of silly
route with it which at first I was like
but then totally worked for me yeah Paul
Giamatti is a rhino I almost they could
have had anyone I'm gonna confuse why
they chose Paul Giamatti it seemed like
he was he was like y'all come out for
two days Thanks and I like the the
mechanized suit and I love how
everything revolves around Oscorp
nothing is random in this it's all
focused about there's just one company
that experiments with animal genetics
and that's why all this stuff is
happening yeah and it to me anything
that's focused with logic like that just
seems so much better yeah and a lot of a
lot of the reviews of him reading i'm
complaining that it's convoluted and
thinking idea just how polluted at all
um I will say this spider-man holds a
very special place in my heart so like I
may be coming from it with that lens um
but this is a really really fun movie
spoiler alert big spoiler alert huge
spoiler alert until probably the last 15
minutes when Gwen Stacy dies exactly the
same way in the comics I mean there's no
bridge but she'd yes spider-man Jude
it's catches her it stays with house man
3 feeling when Stacy I really do like
the way compared to Mary Jane was always
this in the Tobey Maguire movies they
sort of damsel in distress she's kind of
dumb she's an actress she's like I don't
know what I'm doing and she's always
getting like in trouble someone has to
savor gwen stacy is exactly the opposite
she's a science whiz she's gonna go to
Oxford University and she's super smart
and like she's the brains real she's
smarter than Peter Parker I think that's
yeah awesome and just from
and a character standpoint the way that
they built her as being like Peters rock
is really really effective and like I
said their chemistry together when she
when she dies like you feel it and
Andrew Garfield plays it beautifully um
but he loses his Center because she is
the person who kind of keeps him going
yeah for me the death I feel like so
much more should have happened
afterwards and actually right on IMDb
there was an entire fight scene filmed
immediately after that death which I
feel like kind of needed to be there
maybe but I guess I cutting him in great
goblin yak between Peter Parker and
Harry Osborn because I felt like she
dies and then we move on and then the
movie ends very quickly after that I
kind of want more which I'm sure is
going to be the third movie but I was
confused as far as also this is aimed at
kids you know the director showed a very
like strong death like I was like even I
was moved and I'm not nine years old so
like yeah so overall I really really
liked it David I'm just very satisfied
as a spider-man fan I I was I was about
seven out of ten seven out of town I'm
going I'm going eight and a half now I
gave the last 19 that was right after i
saw i put that probably at around 27 now
um so I've had some time to process this
I'm going to eight and a half um but let
us know what you think comment below let
us know you think the amazing spider-man
2 and make sure you buy tickets from
fandango click right here
until next time I'm Ryan and I'm dated
thanks for watching